hello my name is Ankur Kotwal and
welcome to this week in Android
development for februari 17 2014 last
week Leon showed us how to use the
google cast sdk for android whilst
catherine showed us how to connect to
Google Play services using the Google
API client catherine also put together a
special app to help you connect with
your Valentine and this was actually
part of a two-part dev bite series
called just for us Todd gave us less
than 3.1 in the ongoing play games for
iOS series where he showed us how to use
leaderboards to connect with your loved
ones Fred's mystery dev bite series has
been revealed and it's on the media
router framework so please be sure to
check it out and Todd and wolf are going
to explain turn-based multiplayer gaming
in the latest episode of game on for
this week in Android development I'm
Ankur Kotwal because maybe you're going
to be the one that saves me and after
all you're my Wonderwall